I think I can sum up the show for you
with one word nothing nothing nothing
what does that mean it wasn't until
episode 3 of season 4 that Seinfeld gave
itself that famous description as a show
about nothing not until this episode
called the pitch which mock documents
Jerry and Larry David's first meeting
with NBC executives nothing happens on
the show
see it's just like life the interview
since then like this reddit AMA from
2014 the creators admit that the moniker
was only really a joke and that they
were actually surprised by how much it
caught on with audiences and yet I think
the nothing in question is a good lens
to examine this show through to explore
what makes it different from other
sitcoms and so popular still today now
when you think of Seinfeld the first
thing that pops into your head probably
isn't 19th century French novelist
Gustav flow Barre but there's a
connection here that I think is worth
exploring a little bit see flow Barre
was a pioneer of literary realism in
large part responsible for raising the
status of the novel to that of a high
art so intense was his dedication to
craft that in a letter to Louise Calais
in January 1852 he wrote what seems
beautiful to me what I should like to
write is a book about nothing a book
dependent on nothing external held
together by the internal strength of its
style now of course a novel like Madame
Bovary isn't literally about nothing the
book explores themes of freedom love and
human stupidity and explores them deeply
the differences that flow bear instead
of getting at these themes through
subject and plot like his predecessors
treats them with style he doesn't just
want to string you along with multiple
suspense heightening narrative
developments he wants to bring you into
the text itself to look there for the
carefully
instructed meanings that he's built for
you so when flow Barre says he wants to
write a book about nothing what he
really means is nothing like the
established forms and genres against
which he situated himself indeed in any
art form the positive value of a work in
question has to be determined against or
in negative relation to the other kinds
of work already present in the form by
the 1950s a number of conventions for
the television sitcom had already been
established family had become the
dominant setting for the situation
comedy these sitcoms feature
predominantly white middle-class
families sometimes with kids sometimes
without dealing comedic ly with a
problem of the week before resolving the
issue and coming together into a kind of
unity so that they could do the same
thing again next week well what are we
waiting for I'm going to DJ we we sure
are come on by the time of the Mary
Tyler Moore Show in the 1970s the
nuclear family had been partly
supplanted by the work family but the
sentimental unity of the group was an
even stronger value thank you for being
my family with Cheers in the 80s the
sitcom began to break from its by then
staid conventions there was less
sentimentality less lesson learning and
the transition from family as family or
family as co-workers to family as
friends and yet still there was a drive
toward unity namely in Cheers the
romantic unity between Sam and Diane
which gave the show of familiar dramatic
weight okay okay okay I got it you run
an antique store yeah and and people
come into the store and you will get
involved in their lives
what person who runs an antique store
gets involved in people's lives so
someone comes in to buy an old lamp and
suddenly I'm getting them out of a jam
it wasn't until Seinfeld that the
conventions of the sitcom were
deconstructed fully when all forms of
unity familial and especially romantic
were wholeheartedly abandoned for
Seinfeld these additional elements were
just so much fluff forget the story you
gotta have a story
who says you gotta have a storm like lo
bear's novel Seinfeld or goes the
traditional subject matter of the sitcom
its didactic sentimentality centered
around a family of one kind or another
in favor of stories held together by the
internal strength of its comedy now this
isn't to say that Seinfeld doesn't have
plots
Seinfeld plots are among the most
sophisticated of the genre but the plot
drivers are different from its
predecessors instead of goal oriented
principal characters achieving their
ends based on actions that they take
Seinfeld frequently has its characters
make some small action on a whim at the
start of an episode a certain cast
member of Melrose plays really you ever
seen the show no then spend the rest of
the half-hour dealing with the
unintended consequences of that actually
Kimberly steal Jo's baby and if they do
set out to achieve a goal even if they
get a turn done they often fail in the
end because of circumstances beyond
their control can I be expected to have
the same expertise as people who own
this equipment in Seinfeld's more
complicated narrative small events from
one character's life can determine
outcomes in another any action that any
character takes has unexpected
consequences so that coincidence merely
a device in traditional goal-oriented
sitcoms becomes the rule on Seinfeld
that's the guy officer
me Larry David's famous no hugs no
learning policy for Seinfeld is in
keeping with a show based on refusals
refusal to entertain sentimental endings
real romance of any kind or the
redemptive power of the family and in
doing so David and Seinfeld rejected the
silently agreed-upon moral standards
that guided every other sitcom to its
weekly resolutions again like Madame
Bovary Seinfeld isn't literally about
nothing but instead of reinforcing
larger moral standards it explored
insanely minut social norms the women
know about shrinkage
what do you mean like laundry
interestingly hilariously it turns out
that while the morals of past decades
have shifted and changed under our feet
these petty behavioral questions about
nothing all that important prove to be
more timeless and timeless Lee funny
than just about everything else should
be the show what yeah
hey everybody thanks for watching
obviously I'm a huge Seinfeld fan so
getting to watch a lot of Seinfeld
episodes to make this video was a blast
also getting to read a lot of flow Barre
because I'm a huge flow Barre fan as
well and I like to say the word below
bear I want to thank you guys so much
because after a couple weeks ago of my
video on Harry Potter I mentioned how
important small pledges on my patreon
were because of the length of time is
more important than than than the amount
and that is because it helps me plan on
this channel what I'm gonna do next
what's coming and after that video a lot
of you guys pledged a dollar or three
dollars and you're awesome for that so
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you we just crossed two hundred
fifty thousand subscribers on this
channel which is a quarter million and
that's a number that I can't really
conceive so I am grateful and that's the
feeling that I'm going to keep putting
out into the world so thank you so much
for that if you want to pledge to my
channel you can go right here and click
there and I will see you guys next
Wednesday for another video
this is so much fun